ladies and gentlemen this is what you've
become for its main event time
miss this let me putting together team
yeah Cody your revenge's revenge assume
I mean we don't have to have a name we
could have no name
[Music]
hey everybody new thor ragnarok trailer
let's break it down there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs that they revealed
from behind the scenes to they have to
deal with fire Lords Serdar as well as
what's going on with Hellas character
they actually combined a couple of
really cool characters from the comics
to give her some new abilities they
teased an infinity gem behind the scenes
and they revealed how Hulk got to Sekar
they revealed what happened at the end
of Avengers age of Ultron while he was
on that quintet so if you didn't see my
Ragnarok video last night I'm actually
doing a Marvel IMAX ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
they just put tickets on sale for this
so this is one of those movies that I
would recommend that you try to see in
IMAX if you can because it is going to
be nuts but obviously like the big new
thing in this is we get a full-blown
look at fire Lords Serdar they have a
little bit of fun with the idea of The
Avengers
I love how Bruce Banner here is just so
blown away by everything around him that
he clearly does not notice that Thor is
trying to steal the Avengers name and
pass it off like it's his idea so if you
weren't sure what's going on with Hulk
and banner in the movie like all this
Planet Hulk stuff that happens early in
the movie is all 100% hope Banner is
nowhere to be found so presumably after
they have their chill out moment then
you see them looking at that big hole in
the sky that's the first time that he's
been banner in a long time so the big
green guy has been in the driver's chair
since Avengers age of Ultron now I know
everybody's like what was going on
between now and then did he go into
outer space the quinjets aren't designed
to do that how did this all work
they finally confirmed that Hulk
crash-landed on stack are at the end of
Avengers age of Ultron so I think you
know because guardians of the galaxy
introduced the idea of all these gates
in space that help you travel through
wormholes all over the universe that's
how he got there because otherwise it
would take an entire lifetime just to
get to the other part of the galaxy
forget the other part of the universe
they jump to return I know hey we're
about to do 700
[Music]
[Applause]
so in the way that you've seen the
guardians of the galaxy flying around
outer space within their own galaxy
Marvel hasn't completely mapped out what
the universe looks like yet so it's
still open to interpretation but for all
intents and purposes
Sekar is on the other side of the
universe from Asgard you know I wouldn't
say that Asgard is anywhere close to
Earth it's just that they have the
Rainbow Bridge which is essentially a
wormhole machine that could take you to
anywhere you want to go so if you're
wondering how it's possible for hope to
get to Sekar so quickly after avengers
age of ultron just assume wormholes
that's also kind of how chris hemsworth
explained when hella banishes him from
Earth like kicks him into outer space he
lands through a couple wormholes and
winds up on the trash planets a car
which is kind of what it is it's kind of
like a garbage dump where all the
universes trash winds up at the end of
all the different wormhole lanes which
is why everything looks so cobbled
together Jack Kirby style they use it as
an opportunity to introduce all this
color and make it look like something
out of a Jack Kirby comic book in Tom
Hiddleston actually said this funny
thing about hella so talking about them
combining characters from the comics so
just to put this out there necro sword
so if you don't immediately know what
that term implies what I'm talking about
hella they basically combined Gore's the
god butcher with the hella character
from the comics in Tom Hiddleston has
this funny roundabout way of talking
about infinity gem really powerful
related things he says going into this
conflict
everyone is under estimating hellas
power she has a secret that blindsides
them all and she's been lying in wait
all this time for the stage to be set
for her return she's invincible
she is all-powerful and so everything
about her is surprising to Loki and Thor
as well the other producers said that
they used the movie to sort of challenge
your deeply held beliefs about some of
these all-powerful characters and I
think they're mostly talking about Odin
about Thor about the gods in general the
fact that they might be unkillable they
might be eternal they use the word
eternal when they were talking about
shaking your deeply held beliefs so
Asgard itself is eternal so I think that
when they talk about Thor not being able
to walk back on the big changes that
happen during the movie
just gonna wipe the board clean so that
if they want to do a fourth or movie or
they want to do Asgard in the other
space-based movies like Guardians three
or whatever other franchises they
develop they can completely redesign it
and it totally works from a logic
standpoint like oh yeah Asgard went
through Ragnarok so of course it looks
different than it looked in the first
couple of Thor movies so let me know
what you guys think about the idea of
them combining gore the god butcher the
character with Hellas powers and
infinity gem like they didn't explain
exactly how that's gonna work but they
did say for the most part the reason why
they added gore the god butcher to her
abilities is so that she could just
manifest as many weapons as she wants
like it's actually in this clip right
here so this kind of explains how she's
able to take out all this army at the
same time then when you see the
Asgardians on the bridge with the green
glowing eyes that look like they've been
mind-controlled by her that's probably
soul gem so that's really what I'm
taking to me when Tom Hillston says
she's invincible she has a secret power
that nobody knows about
so I probably talked about it in the
past before we could talk about it more
after the movie actually comes out but a
lot of her abilities in the comics read
like the abilities of the soldier so it
just sounds like everything worked out
with her character so just a heads up
because everything's getting ready to
come back on television really soon
there's a lot of comic book stuff that
just dropped I know in related DC news
you guys have been asking for new
Justice League so I'll probably do a
video for the Deathstroke episode for
arrow it's gonna be a two-part episode
that'll tell Deathstroke's origins story
will meet an adult version of Jericho
and they confirmed that another
Smallville character is going to star on
the Titans Nightwing TV show so I'll
probably do videos for that this weekend
like the Deathstroke video will probably
be next but if there any other Marvel
videos that you guys want me to do for
the movies or infinity war just let me
know in the comments below
congratulations to the latest IMAX take
a giveaway winner mr. raccoon please
private message me on the back end of my
channel it's on the about page so I can
get your contact details what'll happen
is is I'll announce a new winner the
next time I post a Marvel video so just
leave all your requests for what you
want that to be but while you wait for
everything click here for that infinity
war post-credit scene video and you can
click here for brand new flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight